in 2015 it was Greece's financial crisis
keeping customers away from the free
thinking zone bookstore and cafe at the
time pages weren't being turned coffees
weren't being served and the overall
situation looked bleak owner Adia really
worried her small Athens business might
not make it despite all that what she
called the free thinking zone survived
now though it's the corona virus
pandemic that threatens to switch the
shops lights off for good these days
independent booksellers around the world
are finding it increasingly difficult to
stay in business hi everyone this is
Maya at the bookstore I want Mari on
Reiner owns and operates the run for
cover bookstore in San Diego California
its doors are temporarily shut and its
future is uncertain but customers are
still ordering titles book business
world to get our hands on books because
everyone has had to change overnight the
way they do business Mari on who
fulfilled a lifelong dream by opening
her store a year and a half ago has
turned increasingly to social media to
keep book buyers engaged alerting them
to works that have come in and orders
that have gone out she's even started
digital mother-daughter storytime
sessions but she says nothing will ever
replace face-to-face interactions with
fellow book lovers the connections has
really been the greatest gift of my
bookstore and not being able to do this
in person right now is obviously very
very hard
my name is it's not just booksellers
getting more creative and engaging
readers in the era of Kovach 19 authors
are - such as sanam maher in pakistan
who along with a friend started the stay
home stay reading series
she worked from her home in Karachi I
wanted to create something that allowed
those authors to put their work forward
in as public a space as possible to
allow just readers from all over the
world to access their work to just check
it out see if they're interested to be
able to read from their work and also
really to have a moment when they could
share it and celebrate it
writers speaking directly to readers
offering stories as a way to escape even
if just for a few moments the seemingly
constant barrage of bad news Mohammed
Jim Jim al Jazeera